c'est un arbre ancestral majestueux à
l'histoire étonnante l'anecdote fait
état d'un botaniste du xviiie siècle
passionnés qui dû débourser 40 écus pour
se procurer cinq jeunes ginkgo biloba
une fortune à l'époque pour cette
essence originaires de chine et dont le
jardin botanique de tours possède sept
exemplaires depuis 170 ans
cet arbre a poussé de façon assez
biscornu il aurait dû pousser bien droit
comme tous les dinka biloba qui sont des
arbres normalement très dressé avec un
vraiment un sommet mais il a vécu
beaucoup de choses dans sa vie des
tempêtes des inondations des orages qui
nous en fait cassé des branches
principales et qui font que cet arbre
est particulier un arbre atypique à qui
l'on prête de nombreuses vertus
médicinales
celui-ci à d'ailleurs été offert à la
ville par le docteur bretonneau qui
donna son nom à l'hôpital voisin un
passé et une beauté qui permettent entre
autres à ceux de ginkgo biloba de
concourir pour le titre du plus bel
arbre de l'année et de représenter le
centre val de loire
on est je pense le seul arbre du
concours être un arbre urbain en effet
on est en plein centre ville
et ça c'est aussi un symbole important
pour nous à la ville de tours de montrer
que la biodiversité en ville
elle peut exister et elle peut nous
émerveiller tous les jours pour cette
promeneuse quel que soit le palmarès
final cet arbre a tout d'un gagnant elle
vient d'ailleurs régulièrement
l'observer surtout en cette saison où
ces couleurs sont flamboyantes les
majestueux et on né peut que venir
l'abhorré l'admirer d'être bien enraciné
ça permet aussi de s'élever très haut et
mérite d'être une vedette et si vous
aussi être tombé sous le charme de ce
géant
rendez vous sur le site de l'ot nf
dernière ligne droite pour voter le 5
janvier prochain